you must be I I was just telling Andy I  just got back from Oslo I went to Oslo  for a weekend Oslo Norway and it really  it's pretty intense you've been on this  worldwide press junket yeah for the  movie passengers and you've been  everywhere you went to Moscow yeah I was  in Moscow's I reckon I might ever been  I've never been there what's it like oh  it's great I don't know what the fuss is  about it seems like it's really nice  like they're just KGB bodyguards all  around and it's beautiful and snowy and  it was great yeah I experienced in fact  in the in the 15 hours I was there I  experienced all of the culture really  experience everything there is to know  yes about the great Russian Empire  everything yeah yeah I learned it all  yeah yeah pretty cool pretty cool I you  also went to it was lovely  you